how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
it has been two years since avengers end
game was
in theaters and to celebrate robert
downey jr released today
on twitter and instagram a behind the
scenes video
of an avengers in-game deleted scene
between him
and his adult daughter morgan in seoul
world
after tony stark snapped as we can see
here tony stark snaps and then he looks
around because he doesn't really know
where he's at
but then he turns around and he sees
morgan but she's an adult
now now disney actually released this
scene on disney plus
so we actually do know what happens here
the reason that tony turns around is
because
morgan says hey a very confused tony
stark walks up to her and asks
do i know you in which she replies we're
pretty close
actually and tony suddenly realizes
that's because she is his daughter just
grown up
because you're
it's a pretty emotional scene where tony
actually questions the decision that he
made
to snap he questions whether his
daughter and his wife pepper potts are
actually going to be okay
with him gone because a big part of
avengers in-game was tony saying that he
can't risk his family and of course that
meant a few things he meant he can't
risk undoing the snap because whatever
happened in the past five years can't be
undone because that's when morgan was
born but of course he also couldn't risk
dying because he couldn't leave his
family they needed him and this is a
concern that he expresses to morgan in
what appears to be
soul world now we won't really talk
about how the whole time thing works in
the soul world but clearly this
is his daughter and it's a daughter who
has lived a full life
as she comforts him and tells him that
she's okay and that she's proud of him
i'm proud of you
and sad
if you're happy i'm happy and tony comes
to terms with what he did because his
daughter's happy
and proud of him and of course the scene
has to end with an i love you
3000.
i love you 3 000. so for those of you
who have not seen it or don't have
disney plus that is the deleted scene
it's definitely something i would have
liked to see on screen but it's nice
that disney plus released it and again
the man himself robert downey jr tony
stark released the behind the scenes
video of this today
celebrating two years of avengers
in-game and it really doesn't seem like
two years
but marvel's future is definitely very
very bright right now so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest marvel videos
let me know what you think about this
scene in the comments down below and
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof